like you thank the organizers for
inviting me and giving me the chance to
speak here so everything going to talk
about today's don't work with Swan
tiongson from Uppsala University and
it's a top agree that lies at
intersections say of probability and
coma tarick's where I think some input
maybe or some physical ideas might be
useful so what is the motivation here
for for this for this project so the
motivation was read to study the number
of copies of H in a random graph GNP so
think of maybe for the moment of wanted
to count the number of triangles you
want to count the number of four cycles
and so on and so forth this is a very
important quantity in random graph
theory I would actually say it was a
driving force in the development of
random graph theory so for example if
you look back into the very early papers
and random graphs just the question does
the random graph GNP contain a copy of H
this was addressed in one of the very
first papers on random graphs by
addition rainy using the first and
second moment method in fact they only
obtained some partial results for these
graphs this was later refined by bola
Bosch in the 80s was fully resolved can
get really getting a better
understanding of the second moment
method I would say furthermore the
number of copies of age has been tested
for a number of other methods so for
example the method of moments to
establish possum convergence or also the
stein shen method was also applied to
this random variable and some early work
by Bob or for the more also some more
classical questions maybe from
probability theory like asking the
question when is this random variable
asymptotically normal was also studied
for this random variable in the late 80s
by under her chin ski and each time one
can say that the application or the
study of this random variable has
usually led to a deeper insight into
some of the tools and techniques they
were nowadays using for the purpose of
this talk today I want to focus here
maybe the following result here is
really the most classical result
misdirection so we're asking when or
what is the probability that your random
graph GNP contains no copy of age so
there are a number of different
motivations for studying this random
variable some may become more from some
extreme low Ramsey type question but I
think in general this is also on its own
a very interesting question said just in
probability theory and it was a very i
would say break the result in the late
80s by yon sandwich knockin boots in ski
who showed were able to nail down the
probability that the random graph
contains no copy of age say up to
constant factors in the exponent okay so
they were able to show that the
probability that your random graph
contains no copy of age decays
exponentially in this parameter five age
where files of age comes from a certain
minimization problem and if you've not
seen this before so the reason why this
quantity is perhaps not so simple as you
would like is that sometimes you need to
search for the reason why your random
graph G&P contains no copy of age so for
example if i draw some click with some
one sort of outgoing edge attached to it
then it turns out that actually the
reason the real reason why your random
graph will not will not contain a
function object is basically because it
will not contain a copy of KFOR so in
some sense you must look for the the
main obstacle and this is sort of where
this quantity comes from so maybe from
the modern perspective what is the
probability of having no copies that all
mean well we can interpret this as a
special case of the lower tail problem
where the lower tail problem asks for
what is the probability that your random
graph has too few copies of age and one
way to quantify is if you want to say
your random graph contains 1 minus
epsilon times the expected number of
copies and then you can ask can we get a
similar statement and when I start
looking at this some years ago I was
quite surprised that actually this
question has not been answered had not
been answered in full detail so there
were only some upper bounds available on
this probability but they were no
matching lower bounds which actually
proved that these results were
essentially best possible this is
something we did here with santhi anthem
we were able to basically extend this
result to the case where we look at the
lower tier we're looking at the
probability of having 1 minus epsilon
times
that number of coffees and I should
mention at this point here that maybe
the form of this result is probably not
not quite of the standard form because
for example if you take maybe the
perspective of large deviation theory
then often for example the n0 how large
the graph needs to be might depend or is
allowed to depend on your parameter
epsilon this result is uniform in the
sense that it holds for any for any
larger than some absolute constant
there's no dependence on epsilon here
the only key restriction is that we want
that this epsilon squared time this
parameter FIH is big and some sense
that's a very natural requirement
because you want to study exponentially
small probabilities and the probability
in question decays exponentially in
epsilon squared times 5 h so it's a very
natural assumption or condition that you
want that this parameter is not too
small say it needs some constant okay so
why should we care about this what is
the motivation so I've already mentioned
that in some sense at least in random
graph theory the study of this fellow
available has been quite quite
influential so the the number of copies
of age has really become a standard test
bed in the area of concentration
inequalities so if you develop new tools
and techniques and typically you'll try
to showcase your methods using these
copies of age we've seen one example of
this for example on Monday in the theory
of nonlinear large deviations yes your
business do you know that you
epsilon square times pi rho this
collision well okay so I'm sure I think
one can sort of patch things together
because what this is just saying is that
if this condition is violated then the
probability in question will be
something like 0.999 or something like
that and then you can use other methods
to determine such constant probability
say use normal approximation so so just
maybe to elaborate on this it turns out
maybe as a fact use maybe different
color that this is somewhat of the
normal approximation form so you can you
look at say epsilon square Phi of H this
is sort of up to constant factors and
ignoring serve the general cases when P
tends to 1 or something like that this
is essentially
this year okay so this is sort of really
of this Gaussian type form so if you
play normal approximation than the other
range you'll get exactly the
probabilities you're interested in yes
okay so I mean so um the point of this
formulation is that yeah I don't need to
make an assumption basically oh okay let
me rephrase this dip yes but Epsom can
go to zero at a certain rate so so this
allows for epsilon going to 0 so you
might be interested in the case where
your epsilon is very very small
maximas not see that matter actually
it's true for for all if you don't book
yes as long as not so much well if it's
a if it's a confidence than I know this
is just some number i mean so we really
want to understand what is the
qualitative behavior on epsilon in this
case okay so maybe your question is
related to maybe in large deviation
theory where you really want to nail
down the constant I think this salvation
usually is a beautiful to epsilon going
to 0 at the same time I of H goes to
infinity is considered kind of slightly
more the regulation because if you know
they be much more e or fixation then
your your understanding that is epsilon
squared is already telling you something
but if epsilon is one-half so affected
to the rebels tells you nothing yes
that's right Oh in some cases but we can
come back to them later I should maybe
mention that my main motivation is a
little bit for more from the
applications perspective so I'm more
than happy here to give away at factor
of 10,000 if that means that I can apply
the result for a wider range so maybe I
don't only cannot only applied for
density or for the intense case but I
want to cover the entire range that I'm
very happy to give away some constant
factors there this serve there's
perspective from the random graph
perspective I think
okay so this was the question concerning
motivation one of us through this
development of tools in the second
question is exactly what we were
discussed it's sort of falls
intersection of concentration of measure
and large deviation thirion in some
sense this here is sort of more like a
concentration in the quality type get
uniform bounds okay so after this
motivating example what is of the the
general outline that I'm trying to aim
for so first I want to introduce a tool
that's very widely used in in random
graph theory perhaps it's not so well
known in other communities which gives
is a concentration in equality for the
lower tail and our main aim will be to
basically match that in the soap what I
would call the so-called cross on case
okay so this thing will give an upper
bound and we want to give sort of up to
1 plus a glow of one we want to match
that from below showing that the thing
is essentially best possible however the
drawback of this very precise result
would be that it only applies in the
Poisson case so to cover the non cross
in case we need to do some extra extra
tricks and if time permits I also
discuss what open problem namely
concerning the question wit what's the
probability that the random graph
contains no triangles ok so let me maybe
go to this so-called yawn sense
inequality so the way I want to present
it here is in a slightly simplified
setting but I think it captures the
spirit so we want to look at some
binomial random subset so we're given
some sets a gamma and we include each
element independently with probability P
if you want you can also say that
element I is included independently with
probability P I so this is just the
product space and then we have some some
collection of edge subsets s and we're
interested in how many of these edge
subsets are present in this binomial
random subset gamma P okay so think of
for example you want to copy how many
triangles of the random graph have then
what we're interested in how many three
element subsets formula
angle are present in the edges of your
binomial random graph one way to
formalize this here is to say let's look
at X as a sum of these indicator random
variables where the indicators
represents the event that your set a is
contained this binomial random subset
okay so think again of the triangle
example s will be the collection of
three element subsets forming a triangle
and then this event is just evaluating
to one if all these three edges are
really present and you might wonder now
House of general is this what are the
risk we love restrictions and the real
restrictions will be that somehow we're
looking at the sum of indicators but
they need to have a special form they
need to be basically increasing that's
the key limitation here so to state the
inequality let me maybe very briefly
introduce one more parameter though
perhaps it's not so crucial so first of
all just to unify the notation I always
denote by really expected value of x
which is of course nothing else than
some of these indicators and then I want
to introduce one more parameter delta
which will somehow measure how dependent
are my random variables and one way to
do that is to say okay I want to sum
over all pairs of overlapping indicators
meaning of all pairs of indicators which
are dependent
for all pairs a be in s where a is not
equal to B and where they have some
intersection this just means that they
that these two indicators AI and a B I'm
sorry I be that they are be dependent
somehow this will measure how dependent
are these random variables and the key
point is if for example you look at in
DF indepent independent summons then
this parameter will be zero so general
the idea will be if this parameter is
very small then work then there's not
too many not too many dependencies if
you think again of the triangle example
what this basic is measuring it it's
measuring the expected number of pairs
of overlapping triangles and you re
normalizing it by the expected value so
if this parameter is very small this
means that at least in expectation most
of the triangle should be disjoint which
is very natural for the proton range
okay so now that we've discussed the
setup let me maybe just State this
Jensen's inequality which i think is
very nice i should say the name yawn
sense in equality i think was coined by
by Joe Spencer not by answer itself and
so what this inequality basically says
is that you get some channel finish line
type inequality in the case where you
have dependencies ok so you're looking
at what's the probability that X is at
most 1 minus epsilon times the expected
value and you get some upper bound of
the form exponential in some parameter 5
minus epsilon times the expected value
divided by 1 plus Delta again and take
my word for it if Delta is equal to 0
this is exactly the same expression you
would get if you apply your standard
moment moment generating function
technique this channel type technique ok
so the main punch line here is if Delta
0 you actually recover the classical
channel tied bound I should say that
when this inequality was first developed
in the late 80s it was really quite a
break to really changed a lot of the way
proofs were working because the
gave access to lead to these
exponentially small probabilities which
at the time were very very difficult to
get and still nowadays this is really
widely used in probability comet Oryx or
comet all probability so it's very
natural to ask we have this very widely
used tool how good is it what can we say
about the quality are we giving away a
lot when we apply this improves and now
so if you're asking yourself how good is
my concentration inequality there are
different ways we can play the game one
way to play the game is to say I just
show you one example where its best
possible and the argue ok so we cannot
improve it if you want if you want to
play that game ok it's very simple just
look at the independent case where delta
is equal to zero this just reduces to
channel pounds and we know the channels
pounds our best possible okay but the
question is what does this really tell
you right we we introduce this
inequality exactly to cover the
dependent case so if you argue that in
the independent case is best possible
and that really doesn't tell us very
much furthermore I'm really aiming more
to inequality of the form if your random
variable satisfies a few conditions then
its best possible no matter whatever no
matter what your random variable is as
long as it satisfies these conditions
okay so in particular maybe one thing
that might seem intuitive is that if you
stare at this form for a while well as
long as Delta is pretty small risk of
close to this channel type exponent and
furthermore if the data parameter said
well the Delta measures the dependency
so as long as Delta is small this
exponent here looks Chan of like so so
maybe there's some hope that is still
best possible in that case as well so
maybe we can prove a lower bound of this
form if Delta is equal to delta's little
o of one maybe we can sort of prove a
lower bound of the same form up to this
little of one term here it is sort of
more than in the large deviation context
and so this is what we're able to do in
the approximately prasanna range
so let me maybe introduce one more
parameter for this so this parameter
will will sort of say it's the maximum
over the expectation of these indicators
in other words it's an upper bound for
the probability that one of your
indicators is one and so what we're able
to show is that if Delta and pie this
parameter we just used go to 0 and
epsilon squared times the expected value
tends to infinity then we can sort of
nail down the asymptotic behavior of
this probability exactly as this
functions this phi of minus epsilon
times the expected value ok so this
gives us a very good control over this
lower tail probability and you might now
ask yourselves what about these
conditions are they their natural or not
and so I think that here this assumption
the excellence creme you tends to
infinity that that's a very very natural
assumption because hear what we're
saying is you're looking at the decay
that exponential epsilon squared times
the expected value so if you really want
to study exponentially small
probabilities this quantity better
should go to infinity but now the
questions of course what about these
other two two parameters so let me
perhaps mention that for example
if you apply say the stein shen method
here then one thing you can show is that
the total variation distance between X
and the random variable that is a
Poisson random variable with expectation
rear is bounded from above exactly by
the sum of these two parameters so this
is Stein shame
so in other words if delta plus the spy
both 10 20 then really you can say that
your random variables approximately plus
on so in that sense this condition is
quite natural in fact I would say that
if we even go on high level both of
these conditions are conceptually very
natural because how do we usually teach
the process on paradigm we say that we
if X counts many rare almost independent
events then dear and available should be
approximately prasang okay and so when
is when are these events where well
that's when each of these guys each of
these indicators when that tends to 0 so
that satisfies this property when are
they mostly independent well that's the
case when exactly this dependency
parameter Delta tends to 0 and that
we're looking at many events is for
example also implied here by this
assumption so
okay so now these two very natural
assumptions we can nail down this
probability and then we already
discussed a little bit here here there's
no hidden parameter where that we assume
to be large compared to Epsilon we just
make these assumptions and are these
assumption we can prove this asymptotics
so it's a very things satisfy
satisfactory answer to this question
furthermore if we say relax the
condition that Delta is tiny well we can
still say something maybe not as precise
as this year but we can still sort of
tell you the DK up to constant factors
so
let me say one or two remarks here so
again the main confusion this work was
to prove and matching lower bound the
upper bound this was only following from
this nonsense inequality and if you've
not seen this before so for the special
case epsilon equal to one it's very easy
to construct a matching lower bound but
unfortunately that does not extend to
the general case but let me still
briefly indicate that how the special
case epson equal to one goes so it's
like it's from modern perspective more
like an exercise or maybe not even an
exercise so it's just observation that
we're in this setting where all the
random variables are increasing so we
can apply fkg so this is this eunsung
food shack on route in ski lower bound
so they just said ok let's look at
probability that x is 0 because we're
looking at the sum this means that
actually we can write this as following
intersection of the events that all the
individual elements are 0 now each of
these events that your indicator is 0
right this is sort of recall each of
these things in event of the form are
these in these edges present for example
in my random graph so all these guys
here are decreasing events so in the
product space we can apply fkg or
actually here Harrison equality would be
enough so this is lower bounded by this
product
so now we just do the usual rewriting
write this as 1 minus this expectation
in order to convert this product into
some then we need to use the fact that
Delta tends to 0 okay because this means
that each of these elements here will be
small then we can you can convert this
into a sum so they suggest then become
so sort of a special case episode 21
it's very simple but it's not at all
clear how to extend such a calculation
to the general setting at least under
these minimo assumptions okay and I I'm
not going to say too much about it how
this proof actually works so let me just
mention that it uses variety of
different things so we start off with
some kind of herders inequality then use
correlation inequalities to estimate the
logarithmic derivative and perhaps for
the experts in the one thing I find
quite nice is that we're able to
estimate in some case the fractions of
certain of these Laplace transforms by
integrating the logarithmic derivative
not from zero to something but from say
s have 2s but really if you're
interested the technical details I'll
refer you to the paper for the moment or
ask me afterwards so what about now the
Delta tending to infinity case
so far so far I said okay we can nail
down this exponent very precise if delta
tends to 0 we can get up to constant
factors of Delta's at most order 1 so
what about the other case so it turns
out that under certain symmetry
assumptions you can in some sense always
reduce to the process on case at least
if you're interested in a lower bound so
in some sense the strategy will be in
the following suppose you're interested
in the probability that you have too few
copies of X 8 of your graph H then so
maybe here this delta parameter tends to
infinity whether I can promise you and
I'll show that little bit the next slide
is that there's some other graph which
is a subgraph of j which is in this
process on range where the Delta
parameter is order 1 which is related in
this very nice way to the original
probability okay so the probability that
x HS is too small is at least a constant
times this other probability and the
nice thing is now to this probability
now we can apply our lower bound again
and so bootstrap the probability in
question so let's have a quick look at
this so for the purpose of this talk I
decided to use one graph ink is called
this house of Santa Claus
so it's a very popular thing at least in
Germany for children so what I mean is
is this graph here when H is
this graph here and so if you apply the
machinery that we've seen so far then
you would get the following to estimate
so it turns out that if P is very small
said most n to the minus one-half then
we can nail down the probability very
precisely and if creating this
intermediate range we can still get it
up to constant factors hey well what
about the remaining range of P well what
is the reason why our methods of the
methods that we discussed so far why do
they break well let's just look at this
copy of KFOR in here if P is much bigger
than n to the minus one half then the
expected number of neighbors say of just
these two vertices is very big because
what's the expected number of neighbors
sets n P squared + n P squared tends to
infinity if P is much bigger than n to
the minus one-half so in other words
what this is saying is that if P is much
bigger than n to the minus one-half you
simply will have overlapping copies of
this Santa Claus graph just because the
code degree will be extremely large okay
so in that range you cannot anymore hope
for any kind of force on approximation
okay so so this is sort of bad news this
technique does not work but maybe you
can still try something else so if you
do the calculation say for P between n
to the minus one-half and n to the minus
two or five you'll notice that what this
Y answers inequality tells you is that
say the exponential decay scales
exponentially in epsilon squared times
the expected number of copies of K for
and now the observation and when I first
saw this this was really now you think
that something magic is happening so the
ideas where it turns out that if P is in
this range then this Delta parameter for
this K for this will now be order one in
fact if P is much smaller than n to the
minus two or five it's actually little o
of 1 so now for at least four k for we
can apply a usual or around and get
something of this form it's not just the
question is how can we late maybe the
number of K fours to the number of
copies of this Santa Claus graph so what
we're going to do it seems very very
generous on first sight so what are we
interested in we're interested in the
event that we have too few copies of
this of this graph so to make my life
easier i'm going to introduce here this
event DJ which says that the number of
copies of j is too small so what really
interested in is this probability of of
this event and now i'm just going to be
very generous i'm going to do something
that might seem strange on first sight
so i'm going to say okay this is bound
from below 5 by this event that we have
too few copies of this graph and too few
copies of age okay so note i've now
stuff thrown in an extra event that's
exponentially small seems like we're
giving way a lot but once we have this
form now we can rewrite it as the
probability that we have too few copies
of k 4 multiplied by the probability we
have too few copies of age condition on
having too few copies of KFOR in the
nice thing is we know how to apply lower
bound to this so if you get some control
of this conditional probability we're in
pretty good shape let's maybe do a quick
check in some border cases so let's look
at epsilon equal to 1
so in case epsilon equal to one you say
trivially have
what so let's just rewrite this now make
this explicit so we're interested in the
probability of having too few copies of
the center closed graph conditional
having too few copies of KFOR okay but
in a special case epson equal to 1 we
can just rewrite this you can just say
okay this is equal to the probability
that we have no copies of of H condition
on having no few no copies of KFOR and
in this case it's trivial if you have no
copies of KFOR you can have no copies of
age but again if you want to do anything
like that when you have some epsilon
couple number of copies involved then
things get more messy okay but
so this is sort of the plan that the
outline here is we rewrite this in a
sense saying okay we want lower bound on
this event is basically blame all the
error probability for this other event
and we just need to make sure that this
conditional event is in good shape so
somehow there might be or there seems to
be a list from the philosophical point
of view some relation to tilting
although I don't quite understand with
whether there's a formal relation or not
because if this is true if this is a now
holds with probability with constant
probability then what we really did is
we took an exponentially small event
that we have too few copies of KFOR we
conditioned I'm inside the event we have
too few copies of age and we conditioned
on another event and this boosted the
probability from expedited being
exponentially small to constant
probability okay so we really converted
a rare a very atypical event into a
typical event which released from the
philosophical point of view is related
to the Stilton idea and large deviation
of theory and I think if we sort of
stare at this picture here again for a
while so if we're saying too few copies
of KFOR how many copies of age it sort
of seems obvious it seems obvious if you
have too few copies of KFOR we should
have too few copies of age but of course
the question is how can you prove
something like that so
let me
and he tried to draw one more picture
here so
let's maybe look at the distribution of
X H so XH we know that it's
asymptotically normal so have some nice
nice shape maybe something like this and
say here's the expected value
so the unconditional world this event
will be over here that we have at most 1
minus epsilon times the expected number
of coffee so this exponentially unlikely
but it turns out and this one can
actually prove if you condition on
having too few copies of KFOR then you
suddenly have been you suddenly are able
to massively decrease the expected value
so the expected value drops from the
expected number of copies of age to 1
minus epsilon times the expected number
of copies of age this one can can prove
so in other words the distribution of XH
condition on this other event hopefully
should look different so I don't have a
proof for the fact that it really looks
like this but intuitively
dutifully you would expect something
maybe like this where now the new
expected value so we're living in this
conditional space and now this suddenly
becomes at most 1 minus epsilon
it's really on intuitive level now you
really should look more like like this
so it should be going on and you think
about this how this this Santa Claus
graph is is built you can basically
think of how do we count all copies of
age well we first count all copies of
KFOR and then sort of try to extend each
copy to the Santa Claus graph and then
maybe using symmetry we can do something
but does not seem to be so easy to make
such a statement fully rigorous however
we were able at least able to prove some
variant of this which was sufficient for
our purposes okay so for those of you
maybe one of the main difficulties is
that while it might be easy to calculate
here so the first moment in this
conditional space calculating this the
second moment or in general the variance
in such a condition space seems quite
quite tedious and without some extra
tricks we do not know how to do that
actually I have question for for that
precisely um you could write this so say
if you are interested in Santa Claus you
could write it as a sum up so if you
have the Cape for all you need is these
other two you know the the roof so this
is like this so you have the indicator
photo k 4 plus an indicator for the roof
and these are independent right yes
that's right so this is the way you can
prove something like this so what you do
let's see let me let me right over there
so um so this is true say in general
that you can write if you're interested
in say the number of copies of age you
can this is true for any sub graph
actually you can always factor it in
some renormalize in content sites EG h
times the expected number of copies of g
multiplied by some other expectation so
let me denote it by y g of h where this
sort of says if i give you a copy of g
how many extensions are there to a copy
of age ok so in this case G would be the
copy of KFOR and then we would need to
extend the thing so this this is by
symmetry you can always prove that and
basically using correlation inequalities
you can prove something similar in the
conditional space so so it turns out
that if you do the calculations and I
don't want to do them here you can
actually prove
so this example g is equal to k force
let me maybe rewrite this
so you get basically the same expression
and then just by definition of this
event this is so this is just by
definition of this event so this shows
that this is at most 1 minus epsilon
times exact number of copies of age okay
but this requires some argument this
uses some correlation type arguments but
it's not so clear how to do this for the
second moment so so I guess my question
was worried the direction you can write
x h as a copy of as a copy of two
independent indicators right so might
the idea was instead of looking at the
variance you could computer cumulus
right because so that that's my question
because the variance of course is very
ugly to compute although there is a
conditional formula for the variance but
for humans you know you could in
principle compute any so Kate or
accumulate because there you have a sum
of independent things let's maybe
discuss it after the thought that would
be quite interesting okay so
and so this was this this reduction step
where we said somehow we can reduce from
having too few copies of age we can
blame it to having too few copies of
KFOR and this is the way we can get our
lower bound okay assuming that we can
implement this step but that requires
some more care and technical
calculations so just take my word for it
you can implement this strategy for any
graph H on intuitive level what you can
do if you for example want to prove such
a statement is that
for proving the lower bound you should
always focus on the graph which attains
the mini moment in here then you can
apply this reduction to that graph and
it turns out that it works but it
requires argue some arguments and the
nice thing about this formula somehow is
that it tells you that really at least
up to constant factors you're pretty
much consistent with any kind of normal
approximation arguments you have this
nice form here in the exponent okay so
let me maybe skip this one and maybe
just come to sort of informal summary
what we we looked at so we were
interested in a lower tail probabilities
and one of the motivations was too will
show that this tool that's quite widely
used in publicity comet Oryx that's
often close the best possible so we saw
that for example if we have certain
natural process on conditions we can
nail down this deviation function
asymptotically at least on logarithmic
scale and this allowed us here to
resolve the subgraph question I
mentioned in the beginning and I think
this at least conceptually this
reduction to the through the possum case
is quite a cute idea and I just want to
finish with one open problem where I
think we I hope there's some kind of
soft argument that might be able to give
something like that namely that we want
to I'm interested in can we prove that
the probability of having no triangles
in the random graph when he is a
constant times n to the minus one-half
that this scales some function of C
multiplied the end to the three-halves
yes i know that the order of magnitude
end to the three house is correct but i
don't know that there's exists such a
function that this is true you might ask
why am I interest in exactly in that
range well the point is I can answer
this question for any other p this is
the only range of here I don't know how
to do it and sort of as a final remark
so i always dream that someone will just
tell me that this is sort of an easy
application may be of some kind of
interpolation or sub additive ax t
argument but I don't know how to do that
let me just briefly indicate sort of one
naive
to prove this so I mean there are some
upper bounds but I don't know if any of
them is best for so so i would say prove
that such a function exists i would even
be happy if you just proved that this
exists i if you even if you don't tell
me what the value is i would already be
very happy vision globale bout to do
this yes so the order of magnitudes n to
the three-halves but i'm asking can you
determine the precise dependence on see
because for any other range i know
exactly what what's going on and so
perhaps I mean this is more meant as a
sort of what it may be too serious
attempt but if you look at the
probability that your random graph g NP
contains no copies of a triangle write
this in particular means that each of
these subsets is triangle free the first
half a second half so you can prove
something like
as the n to P we might scream for some
application of interpolation method but
I don't know how to make anything work
and I'll stop you thank you very much